hello my name is fides and my net worth
is zero dollars
is it actually zero actually
maybe mine is something no you you you
have some money
yeah but no i don't you spend it all
yeah staying at airports just making
money now like the past two months
i spend it i'm not good with my how much
you make in these last few months
i made five thousand i think four and a
half thousand the last month
i spent it all every single point i i
asked my brother to send me money
yesterday for the rent
no you didn't really yeah how much is
rent
750 dollars where california
on your old home you should see his his
place he's got like a room
in this really unique area
where in bad area in los angeles where
was this cheap
i'm not 140th i don't have to say
we'll bleep it out i'll tell you if it's
a bad area or not 48th street and what
got it okay so that's not the best air
it's not bad
yeah it's not bad i never had a problem
yeah the crazy thing is people would
come to my old area and it was like
mid-city los angeles and people oh wow
this is
not the safest year i'm like no it's
what are you talking about like
if you're in the rich areas those are
the places that end up getting like
burglarized and stuff like that
no one comes to mid city los angeles
because i'm gonna go and like rob a
house today because there's valuables in
there
nobody ever thinks that so like i felt
so safe in that area
what do you know about me i've seen your
videos
actually actually wait which ones i
watched almost all of them today really
today yeah seriously how stupid do you
think i
i i well we'll get to that
so how i know you how i know you is when
jack was picking up all my furniture
uh in mid-city you were in the video
and i thought you were a friend of jax
and i was like who is this guy he's like
he comes in with so much
energy and it's wild but i thought he
was just like a high school friend of
you
he's like no that's phidious and he
wants to shake uh he wanted to meet
youtubers with a hundred thousand
subscribers okay that's cool um and then
i saw your video with eric
and then uh jack said you were coming on
the podcast
so i just binged all of your content i
gotta say it's crazy
like you've taken you've taken i'm so so
grateful
so happy and excited it's my i
was i was watching from a long time now
i don't watch every single video but
i i love you guys and i'm so excited i'm
from a country
7 000 miles away from here in europe
and like it's very small country i was
watching you guys online like
now is it in here in this couch like
that's cool
it's so freaking amazing i'm so grateful
yeah this is neat to have you on here
you are you are crazy though i i will
say that like
doing the stuff you've you've taken what
most people would consider to be like a
fun little challenge
and then taking it to the extreme like
ryan uh ryan trehan's content
you know living like turning and living
on a penny or whatever you would take
that and be like living in a penny
uh with with like sub freezing
temperatures
for two months and you could like uh so
your first video that i actually really
enjoyed it you spent an entire week at
an airport
yeah undetected yep i thought that was
actually a really cool idea
yeah i liked it it's it's extremely
expensive to live in an airport
but it's zero rent
it's not bad how long do you think you
could have lived in the airport months
no one would have bad news they are
putting in united states
months like nobody will not like
so many people sleep in the night there
is so difficult for them to notice i
i was kind of worried but like three
days in i was like
it's never going to find out i feel like
we got to do you a little bit of justice
when you when we bring you on here
though okay
because it's nuts yeah okay and then not
only in his content
for those that don't know phidias is a
youtuber you have like a hundred and ten
thousand subscribers
soon to be at a million so it'll be 10
million very soon
and that you do the craziest videos and
not only that but like i was really
surprised to know that like even when
the cameras are off
if we're going somewhere literally
phineas and i went to like this like
really uh like vegan restaurant like
low-key restaurant and phidias we walk
in
and phoenix goes hey like as soon as we
walk in
it's like it's dead quiet no
who said it was it alex or i said that
yeah yeah i don't know why like i like
your videos i don't think i would hate
each other he's like that in person
yeah but he said you were very
uncomfortable being with me
i was uncomfortable but i was like oh my
gosh it was like a lot and we walked in
and he just
yelled and then it just was like dead
quiet and he just walked to the register
with me and he dude
you spent so long at that register with
the girl too and he was like
why did you yell why would you walk into
a place why do you need to make your
presence known
i don't know i think it's kind of fun
for me but
i don't i don't do it in a with bad
intention i do it with people like to
see and maybe laugh or
think that twist you who is this stupid
so you walked by a girl who's eating
alone like a 40 year old woman and you
meowed at her
like i was like sitting down and i look
across like i look like you tell you
guys i'm stupid i look a few tables away
and i see phidious walking towards me
and she's just
meow as he walks by the woman it was so
funny
i loved it why why did you do that uh
i always did that and i really enjoyed
people thinking that
i'm stupid i love it you want people to
think you're stupid
but you're clearly not doing it because
you're stupid you're just like people
thinking that you're stupid no but it's
not that i enjoy the i don't know i
i really enjoy people getting
uncomfortable media teams
i don't know i i don't have bad
intentions yeah i will say that but
i have like i'm like fun playful
intentions
do you do you find it amusing to see
like their reactions like you
so and you're just like it's like
especially here in united states the
reaction is
like like i'm an alien
here's the thing i feel like if you if
you did that in los angeles people would
not bat an eye
i've seen people like running naked
throughout the streets like that are on
some sort of you know chemical of some
sort and these people are walking by
like
like they've seen that before it's no
big deal maybe in las vegas
you get more of a reaction you're not in
los angeles people seem to like it
though that's the interesting part it's
like
i can think of people doing crazy things
but i never like imagine that those who
witness it would
enjoy it but we literally we went to
like a fast food restaurant and there
was this kid vardon antonion he's a
jonah's little brother you know jonah
from davidorek's vlogs yeah yeah
he saw him and you run over to him and
just jump on him
like he literally jumped and put his
wrapped his legs around him did you know
him
no no and they both fell on the ground
and then he just sits and talks with us
for like the next hour and a half and he
he totally liked videos i wouldn't do
that like
it worked like he charmed him vardan
liked it
that's why i said i'm stupid
so that's your get out of jail free
cards i am
you get away so people don't question it
that's like the let's get to the jews
you are a finance podcast guys
right yeah yeah i'm thinking to offer
to you know mr beast yes you heard of
him
yes nice you heard of him yeah i think
so i'm thinking to ask this guy
to invest in my channel and
i think there is a big opportunity in
this like youtube channels
he started a company like from intention
to invest
in channels and what why that
why i want to do this is like i want to
i ask myself a ques
elon musk said to ask yourself a
question how i can make one year plan in
two months how i can achieve it
and when i un and answer this question
for myself
is i i want the best in the world to
guide me like i want access to the best
information in the world
and i'm thinking to offer him to invest
for in my channel
what is your thoughts on that i think
you're too edgy for mr beast
that's that's what i think i think you
you take these these challenges like
though the one challenge i watched that
were i knew you were you were
you're crazy i didn't think you were so
crazy to do the marathon in ice
and your feet you were you were in the
hospital
and you were in a wheelchair for what
two weeks that is dedication to be able
to put up with like that
like i would stop after a few laps
i just feel like okay guys i like if you
stopped halfway through i would have
been impressed i'd be like wow
that's crazy but you actually make me do
this make sure that they understand that
i run a half marathon barefoot in the
snow
yeah yeah you got frostbite sevilla
you should have seen the photos that he
couldn't include them on the youtube
video because they were
gonna see it was so i don't have my
phone okay yeah actually it would be
funny to get your reaction all right
now obviously we can't include these
photos in the podcast because they just
they're
they're very gruesome but i was naked
taking these pictures
yeah i'm kidding here's the thing
i get grossed out by stuff really easily
like i see
anything like this i can't look at it so
you're gonna get my honest reaction
oh oh oh no no
no no no no no
holy oh my god
that was a good reaction guys good job
i do not remember looking at that back
to my stomach alex you want to come see
guys is it really that bad yes you want
to come see yeah i'll come check it out
i'll be honest if you get weird like
weirded out by that stuff
don't look at it no i don't i don't i'm
that's disgusting but i'm not i'm not oh
it's a video yeah dude it looks like a
horror movie
here's the thing so so in term like
there's got to be i feel like there's
got to be some block in in the brain
where you're able to push past like
physically injuring yourself because you
got to think like
your mind is going to prevent you from
doing that to your feet like that's not
good for survival
so there's something that's like you
know you are a survivor you are a doctor
survival expert
yeah it's like because your body wants
to stop
but so like your mind is pushing past
like the physical limits
and one thing i want to mention that i
don't mention too often in videos is
that we do actually have a mentorship
group down below in the description
where you could meet with me every other
week and you can also talk to jack
every other week as well we do zoom
calls we talk for about an hour an hour
and a half you can ask me whatever
questions you want it's a really small
group so we have a lot of one-on-one
time so if that's something you're
interested in joining the link is down
below in the description
i don't know i i think uh as far as mr
beast
being an ev i can't i personally can't
say i don't want to speak for him i
but let me ask you i mean why do you
need the investment how much money do
you need
so and where would it be this is the
interesting part that i was i was asking
jack for advice so i'm not 100 sure that
i want to do it
it seems like a good idea in my brain
because but it has to be a deal
that he is motivated to do because and
jack said like just offer him 10
of your adsense for lifetime for free
and he will be like notice and help
but i want to make like a situation that
he's actually have skin in the game
and he actually cares to help me and
like guide me and like give me access to
to give me access to different people
and all this stuff so
i was thinking like maybe 10 percent
it's not about the money money
i will probably start making a lot in
the few months
next so it's like i was thinking for 150
000 investment for like 10 of the whole
business in the future
it's expensive i think it's worth it
because i'm
that confident infideous is successful
here's the thing so so you're valuing
your channel right now at uh 1.5
one and a half million dollars uh you're
taking a huge risk
that you will continue that you you know
that you will perform
that this is something you could see
yourself doing it could take a long time
to make that money back
so with something like youtube you would
want to look to probably make your money
back within about a year
so that that that's just from what i've
seen now i've seen
other big channels that have sold their
adsense rights
big channels like over 10 million
subscribers when they need an investment
they will sell
the adsense on previous videos for an x
amount a big
lump sum usually that pays for itself
within about two and a half years
but that's with an established channel
that has a history of getting consistent
income
so they see this like okay we're going
to give you an investment
we know we're going to make our money
back in this with you it's
it's more of a risk so i would say you
don't need personally
unless you're like i need ten thousand
dollars to go and do this stunt and this
is how i'm gonna
then it might start making sense but i
think you'll be a lot hungrier to do it
a lot better without any investment
i think you're going to be that much
more disciplined and dedicated i don't
think you need it
jack what do you think i i agree i don't
think that you necessarily need the
guidance because you're doing incredibly
well already on your own
uh but i do think that i don't think
that there's anything wrong with
with having you know mr beast giving his
insight on how you can become more
successful as a youtuber that's the best
possible advice you know
advice you can get from anyone and at
least that is a connection with the top
dog on youtube and
honestly 10 of your youtube channel in
the bigger picture
i don't think that that's gonna mean a
lot to you you know a few years down the
road here's the thing
the youtube channel is not where it's at
it's your whole brand it's everything
else you bring in so it would have to be
like
in you whatever you make it's 10 of that
i just i think you would be better off
on your own i i think
probably you could look at what mr beast
is doing listen to his interviews
and it's probably 90 90 he's so upfront
about what works
i i agree in a way but the thing that i
i'm i think is like so difficult like
there is no
youtube university there's no other
information like we are just finding
even
i work with that it's trial and error
yeah so
you want to speed the learning this is
how and like he built
a team he's making scaly as he's scaling
the
his business so i think
even if it's like 10 percent better if
it will make me 10
better like the 10 percent better on
youtube
it equals with so much
compounding the 10 percent like will
make me so much better if it is just ten
percent which i will give him ten
percent
if he makes me ten percent better and
faster
that will lead like this is what they
say in investment that will lead
i will be s in so much
leveraged position from the other guys
so this is how
i think about it i don't think mr beast
is your guy i think uh
nelkis yeah
i think listen because here's the thing
if if you look at mr beast mr beast has
built a really
family-friendly channel where you could
you could sit down your three-year-old
in front of a mr beast video
and enjoy it on the other hand i think
you take things to extremes
more in line if steve will do it i
disagree because first of all steve will
do it
there's no way he can have a channel
that has the success that mr beast has
just because of the nature of his videos
and mr beast also in the beginning he
didn't necessarily have a clean
image when he was first starting out but
as soon as he started to get to the
point where he was getting
10 million plus views of video then he
cleaned out his image which is totally
fine but i think that that's kind of in
alignment with what's
with what uh phidias is doing in youtube
youtube is promoting the videos that are
the safest to promote and even if you
are harming yourself and other people
enjoying it
is youtube going to promote that not as
much as
if something that was probably cleaned
up a little bit more because they
because there
for them it's about the advertising i
don't think phineas has a problem you
don't have a problem cleaning up if that
means that you're going to be
just like mr beast right yeah i don't
have a problem but i i don't think that
first of all i i want to say that one of
the biggest
like breakthroughs that i have in life
is i take what elon musk say
yeah take think about the physicist way
of thinking like you boil things down
and you find the fundamental
truths and like that helps so much with
the youtube thing because
like everyone you say your advice mister
be saying his advice
everyone is saying his advice if
everybody there is
a ton of videos outside that they give
and everyone is saying different things
so i i try to think of myself myself
about this thing with so if you boil
things down i believe like what elon
musk did with the
tesla batteries he boiled him down and
he said
okay we need these things to make
batteries about tesla
we can bring them from other countries
we can manufacture them in our thing and
we can lower the cost
and he started no he didn't take or what
other companies are doing with bad tires
so i've tried to think about that about
youtube so what i think about youtube is
watch time this is the if you boil
things down it's only about how much
you can get possibly to your how much
you can
possibly all people spend on your time
on your youtube channel so
it's watch time so how you achieve that
is the question so i don't think what
you are saying about
clean thing is is the way it's like this
wrapped with
uh what uh what is my fundamental thing
about youtube so
i i wanted to brought that up because
it's a good argument i want to show how
i think about youtube
watch time watch time so i don't think
it's what you said is about
uh me cleaning my contents potential
the best thing because might be for add
revenue but i'm not a hundred percent
if it's going to be like the thing that
will
will bring me more views and clean my
content
i think it would i i always err on this
out of caution that clean content is
more likely to be promoted by youtube
because
they have more of a financial interest
in that succeeding so i've always gone
that route
so we could if you have a difference in
opinion i mean we could agree to
disagree on that but i will i will
probably be pretty confident that i
think clean content
tends to do better overall if if clean
content
makes more brings more watch time so
people watch
more of my time uh more time in my
youtube channel because there is more
broad more friendly i will agree with
that
if clean contents do that but i'm not
sure if it's about the adsense that
brings
more money on youtube i'm not 100 sure
about that i see what you're saying
though that youtube is a business
right i don't yeah i don't think youtube
would ever admit that uh the advertisers
generally dictate what's shown or what's
not i would tend to think it would be
but uh how do you say ryan's last i i
don't trihan drawn or trey i've heard
about treyhand is it traehem
trehan yeah ryan treyhan his penny video
those videos were something that i think
youtube saw as just like
anybody could watch it whether you're
five years old or 50 years old it's just
interesting yeah so i want to say that
i everything i say is maybe estimation
so i'm
probably wrong like i'm not 100 but it's
just from my experience
yeah i am open to being wrong yeah yeah
i think regardless i mean i i know same
with with airac it's just like you know
like i know you're gonna hit a million
subscribers so like i'm not worried
about that
yeah i i personally i wouldn't i don't
think you need an investment
i would be interested in uh investing in
your channel but i'd want such a good
deal
but i would i would be i'd be interested
because i know because i know i don't
want you to invest in my child because
it is the guidance
and you don't have the guidance that i
want you don't have experience in the
grow
in the past that i want to work that's
true so that's true i would tell you to
make uh
how to make less pranking people tell
tell us your story your background
my bug yeah to be a youtuber
so yeah i i was i'm doing youtube for
two and a half years
i slowly discovered that this is what i
love and
like i was watching all these youtube
videos and like i was crying in my
country
i actually think that it's
something that i can be the silly and
like do content also be
the business side it's so beautiful to
me and i i really am so happy doing this
stuff and like
i in my country i didn't see that growth
because i
i was not good with english as well and
like i didn't have the right people
around me like now
i'm i'm surrounded by youtubers that
they have their own learning share they
learning and i was like i have to find a
way because
my dreams is like very important for me
to make them happen
so i i cut one way tiger i broke up with
my girlfriend she
went traveling and i went i came to the
united states my family was super
supportive to the whole process
and i came to united states with like
barely any money from my parents like
just
to barely make it i was washing the
dishes in my house
i was paying half their end in the
beginning i was cleaning the stuff in my
house for
me i was paying 375 rent in my house and
like
it was slowly slowly i was making
friends
understanding studying everyday youtube
making videos like
i had so i do this 24 7 i'm
so excited about this youtube thing and
like i learned i
read books i watch other youtubers i
study and
slowly slowly i it's it's so cool that
in three months in two months i got from
20 000 subscribers to 110 000
subscribers
which is totally crazy for me i'm so
grateful for everything yeah that's kind
of a
sneak peek of myself why'd you break up
with your girlfriend what
was she supportive of it or how did that
uh why not just
keep that going or was it just you
didn't want to do long distance or
yeah i don't think i don't care about
anything else like
except optimizing for productivity so
having
long distance relationship in this point
of my life i don't think it's the best
thing that i can do
so we broke up very happy we
i still laugh here she and we had great
experiences together but i don't think
it's for me in this part of my life
i was speaking with jack what we want
both is
one interaction per month with a guess
that's it
one day what's our interaction jack dude
is what he said was hilarious what did
you tell me verbatim you said ideal
woman
like a girlfriend what what did you say
to me for me
to meet one time with her per month and
half
in the half of the day this is
yes i got married in the video of eric
they surprised me with a marriage i
didn't know so
i'm mad at now wow congratulations and
she said
i did go to invite you wow where'd you
get married
uh in a reach in a rich
place in l.a in a rich house wow
yeah that's a great story why uh why
youtube just you've just graduated
it just gravitated towards it eric
wanted to make a good video
so i was like he was like we're going to
surprise videos
a person to get married it was like for
me to get visas as well to stay here
yeah but i'm not sure this will be the
case because i think she's kind of crazy
and not trustworthy
for me to get married with here so
what makes you say that because i spend
a lot of time with here
oh can't say that okay
what but what what red flags would you
would you say to our audience she's
alcoholic
okay
you don't get bored being around here
right her career
i i think sometimes she get paid with
other people
i love that you are getting
uncomfortable in this conversation
she lives in vegas yeah the algorithm is
always listening so i try to we'll just
let you know
about some of this stuff and leave it up
too i live my life as though there's an
advertiser
who uh wants to be in the channel so i
will
whatever they whatever they want that's
it so i want
to compliment you on something that i
think you're doing great on youtube i
think
you are built i didn't said what i'd
compliment you yet and you said thank
you because you said you want to
compliment me like thank you
so yeah i know yeah yeah
no once the compliment's coming like
already one thing two things i like
about
you like you have a great story telling
that i want to i want to watch to find
out you have a
great storytelling but i think the
bigger advantage that you have is like
you are vulnerable and transparent and
real with the audience and i think
that's why you are getting consistently
high views
because of this relationship that you
built with the audience and it's very
real on youtube i see like emma
chamberlain does this well with her
viewers
and like i think this is very rare and i
think that you are doing great i'm
trying to do a better job on this yeah i
would i would say i have a different
perception of you after hearing your
story
because i think it's easy to see you in
a video as like the
the the rambunctious one who's kind of
like pushing the limit
but when you get to know more about you
i would share more of that story
i think when people really get to know
you like i think i would have like a
serious moment every video
some point probably midway through the
video we're like hey guys for real
here's how i feel here's what's going
on like having a real moment it's kind
of like about the back story a little
bit just 30 seconds and then you could
get back to what yeah
this is what you describe this i think
is what
the secret sauce i i believed in
retention like making all these videos
and like this i'm so excited i'm taking
notes being
vulnerable with the audience and if you
notice when i said stuff about my story
and all this stuff like
that it people want to watch this stuff
it's almost going up so
the people crave this real thing over
the years and
like it's so so cool that
you get to connect with like so many
people if you are like just
real and like be open and vulnerable
with the audience and like
one don't want to show off and like
being uh right like
danny duncan danny it's just yeah danny
duncan
he could just he's himself the entire
video and it's somehow just
really interesting i think if you if you
combined the two of like doing some
crazy stuff
but also just being yourself 15 minutes
just danny dunk in it
i think mr biss kind of missed the point
with the
keeping that is straight fast
pace like optimize have something then
to watch until the end i think
he sometimes i think if the uh i'm not a
i'm not i'm not giving advice but this
is from my
experience i think it's missing this
real youtube thing with the viewer that
this relationship
it will be so i think this is what i
will try to do on youtube like balance
these two things like
keep making better videos and growing
but also have the real thing
i want to give more of myself i want to
connect and be vulnerable and share my
story
with the audience tell us how much
you're making now where's the money
coming from
adsense but i i tried to wait
to not like get any brand deals fast and
like i want to be truthful with my
viewers and not get any scam
brand i want to wait i think i can't
wait we were
making like five thousand four thousand
per month growing very fast
so i think i will slow down a bit don't
do any fast moves
and wait to learn and like do slow moves
i think that's a
better thing what do you think about
that i'm indifferent about i think if
you get a good brand you may as well
just knowing that you're going to
reinvest it all i think
i think your audience would not care i
think as long as it's not like a scam
as long as you do a brand that's good
and you say hey
i'm using this money here here's how
much i'm getting paid for this
putting it all in here or you know
they're making this video possible so i
could do
this i think as long as it's for the
sake of more content i think it's fine
i always say a sponsorship doesn't
necessarily have to lower the quality of
the content that you're putting out with
it in it
yeah i gotta say in the iced coffee hour
these sponsorships
jack and alex spent a lot of time trying
to make these as entertaining as
possible
sometimes even more entertaining than
the actual podcast
and we've we've done these funny uh
skits for this to family that one the
one sponsorship we did with bessie
it's funny and like i think that was
just just as entertaining as the actual
video itself
do we haven't sponsored in this video
yeah uh yeah yeah there's gonna be a
sponsor in this video so
let's go to the sponsor you know what i
realized alex
that you're wearing two different kinds
of socks yes but you know what else
oh what we could just sponsor ourselves
in this video how about that you know
what that sounds great i always like my
own posts anyway
me too and for a limited time if you
want access to the youtube creator
academy where i go over
exactly what you need to do step by step
to start a youtube channel and turn it
into a business
i will give you 200 off when you use the
coupon code
200 off the link is down below in the
description this is everything that i
have learned about how to grow a youtube
channel what makes a successful title
and thumbnail everything you need to do
along the way
it's all down below in the description
and it's 200 off
200 bucks off 200 but
i'm gonna take you up on that deal
because i have this to family to run
wow there we go well thank you guys so
much for watching enjoy the discount and
with that said let's get back to the
video
i don't know if we're going to put it
here
oh yeah we'll all we can do oh we could
always just do it we got public.com
or bankrollcoffee.com they're selling
coffee now bankroll coffee
you got your hotel coffee whoops got all
the 20 cent iced coffee get your coffee
it's crazy tell us some of the crazy
stories he met david dobrik dude how was
that how do you meet david dobrik
so i want to say that i was i'm not
actually amazed by people like
but he was cool like we showed up to
make a video with him with a hundred
strangers in his house
he was like guys open the fridge
and hang around in the like he had so
many expensive items
like that's kind of very cool and humble
in a way
but yeah it was very interesting also
one thing that struck me he said that he
was living in a beautiful house
you reacted in his house here's the
video
so i he said that he he mess with his
creativity living in that expensive
house in that high
in house because he wakes up like i
don't know
may i i think there is something about
that and that's
that's i want to try to know i love
not having any material things i in
comparison to you that i saw your house
you are all about material
the fish tank that gives it away but
yeah i think there is something there
when you have so many things
what do you think about that and his
legs once you have everything yeah you
feel not very motivated
and he said david told him that once he
moved into this nine and a half million
dollar home contrary to his past like
one and a half million two million
dollar home
he feels no like not as much drive and
motivation to go and make these videos
i don't know for me any time i've spent
more money had more motivation to make
it back
so for me even getting a higher mortgage
was like ah well now i got to work even
more
so i don't know i have an opposite uh
opposite perception of that for me
between a house like this and a 10
million
you're moving through you moving here
did you think got
less creativity or more creativity what
do you think it's tough
i would say uh so far this last month
has been
less creativity here because i miss
working out in the backyard
that's that's my house and yeah los
angeles i could work out in the backyard
with like the trees and the birds and
like i got a fountain in the back
and the weather is is better over there
to be able to work in the backyard here
i'm only doing work in this room and
when you don't get a lot of sunlight or
when it's so hot
outside and you're only windows here you
feel less creative i think that's
that's really it but no as far as the
size of the house
it doesn't make it any i actually prefer
more size
things did you you moved you live here
as well what you you had the same
transition with him
uh i would say i feel more creative here
but i was kind of miserable in l.a i did
not like l.a
so i was also way busier in l.a like way
busier so i couldn't focus so much on
the on like the editing and stuff like
that because i had so much going on
because we didn't have alex yet
nice alex yeah
so i would say for me it balances out i
do like the more space i do like the
aquarium here
but i don't i just need a better place
to work and i don't think it's in this
office
so you are thinking like you be more
productive to be outside the house
yeah i work really well outside it's
just so hot here so i told alex
we're gonna get a canopy built in the
back where it's going to be like that
this uh
i don't know how to describe it it's a
little little outdoor canopy
with the screens around it so you could
block it off like little like the
curtains you could block it off
without with a circular table and we
should see about missing ac unit or
something
no no the misters you rich people
you rich people no when i'm planning i
got i want i want to be
gently misted
it's just it's it's so hot in the
butterfly garden
yeah i like that i like that
and uh we i i don't know if we need a
fountain in the back or something
because it's all about creating the
right uh atmosphere to be creative
and to have those those thoughts and
sometimes when you're when you're just
in a room
it doesn't flow as nice graham so if you
put a fountain in the backyard you'd
never turn it on
that's true no this is a fountain in l.a
it's always on
24 7. i find something very weird that
you do guys here
with the finance guys he explained me
that every time that you
you member to the other person like five
dollars because of this
and this is that you own him this is
very weird for me
very weird for what jack paid me
how much was it to lick that 15 15 15
to lick a moldy doughnut i like that
moldy doughnut that's different though
he's saying like let's say like
someone goes and pays for parking and
then the other person's like i'll split
it with you
like i he thinks that it's weird because
he thinks he's just oh it doesn't matter
i'll just go and do it
we're financed guys you are a
multi-millionaire
because that's how you get to be a
millionaire to begin with it's like no
no it is it is it is if i didn't have
those habits
i wouldn't be here today it's because
because i was meticulous about
every single penny i've always been like
that i always will be i hope i i
i i am a millionaire but not like that
it's up to you i mean listen everyone is
free to live their life however they
want
but i've always been meticulous with
spending and it to me it's the same
thing i'm just looking at a body builder
be like oh you could you could eat a
pizza
and they're like well i didn't get like
this because i ate pizzas and be like no
but you could eat a pizza i'm like yeah
but i you don't get like this eating
pizzas it's the same you got to be
disciplined with finance
i love it i respect it but i think this
is not for me the way
that's fair so yeah yeah this is what i
was and that's and that's the thing
about personal finance is personal
so anybody is free to do whatever they
want i truly believe
whatever if it's your money you could do
whatever you want with it
that's what i believe so people
certainly could look at me and be like
oh i wouldn't do that
that's fine i mean it's okay you think
you got uncomfortable
you you you got uncomfortable defending
your position
on that you did look a little a little
defensive
no i mean but but that's that's how i
achieved my dream offending
stefan ladies and gentlemen drop the mic
that's how i think it works that's right
i really respect it and i understand it
do you what do you a hundred percent
i'm a fan he's pretty open-minded jack
but he's also extremely close-minded
what'd you say i don't want to continue
oh yeah graham is hurt
yeah phineas you're gonna have to
no jack i'm being serious yeah phidious
he's hurt
i'm sorry i'm kidding
this is the best prague
[Laughter]
i got one i could be a prank channel we
pranked jack dude we took his
we took his watch yeah
so yeah i i want i want to ask a
question it seems from the outside
that you milk every possible
think uh i i want to offend you not yet
nothing you could say but i think you
are making every
cent possible on youtube you have three
channels you are five channels yeah what
five channels
five channels yeah you are posting uh
like
a lot of videos per week you are
optimizing you have all this stuff
and like i think you are you are trying
to push as much
content like get as much money as
possible humanly possible
and i i think you might be missing on
the long
term doing all this milking thing now
which i understand you are a finance guy
and like you want to optimize and you
want you show the result you are
transparent you are
all wondering i i i agree with all this
stuff but what is your opinion that you
might be
hurting the long term thing milking
everything no okay so you you call it
milking
we call it the infinite monetization
loop
that's all it is it's okay so it's
potatoes potatoes it's the infinite
monetization loop um
so i don't know i think youtube is so
fickle and people come and go on youtube
all the time and i think when you have
an opportunity
it's uh it would be irresponsible to
waste it
so i think in the position that that
i've worked and built up to
it wouldn't make sense to scale back at
this point i just
i first of all i love what i do so for
me it's it it doesn't seem like
milking or or infinite monetization it's
just like
i love it and and then i want to see
like how could i grow how can i expand
how can i continue this
and i mean there's gonna be a point
eventually like i can't see myself like
70 80 years
old be like what's up you guys it's
graham here and you know
i'm sure there's going to be an aspect
to that that what's up guys
what's up you is guys here graham um
but uh but no for me it's like well the
main channel
i've kept up the same upload schedule
since the very beginning so that's not
changing
second channel that's easy i mean that's
just like
that's fun just getting to react to uh
we did one with matthew
lesko just fun it's 30 minutes watch a
video just be hyped up and
and watch that's fine then there's this
so
this is like once a week we get to meet
someone new and have a great time so
i don't mind it um
so between them all it's it's uh you
know even though
there are nine videos posting every
single week to me it doesn't seem
i mean this is normal like it would be
different if we weren't confident in the
content we were putting out
but i really am like i i enjoy the
content we put out i think we provide
great value with the main channel
the second channel is always very
entertaining and it will always have an
audience and it's the family i feel like
is a is a seed that we just planted
that's going to grow
and this is a great way where we just
like we talk and we have an audience
that just likes to sit back relax and
just
like i don't know hear hear our opinions
and i talk
yeah i've always just i've just done
whatever i've wanted to do
and uh if there's a point where i don't
want to do youtube anymore then that'll
be something to approach at that
juncture
but as of right now i think it's it's
all about just like you have a you have
an opportunity
take it so just like your goal is to
make as much
money as humanly possible in the next
few years
i don't even look at the numbers anymore
i mean to be honest with you i mean
it's like uh it would be like a bit like
a game of chess where it's just like
that that is a component of it like
that's that's a pawn that you
you gotta go and like you know conquer
that pawn or whatever but at this point
it's about
just providing a lot of value and i
really enjoy it i i
would tell you i mean if if i were
miserable doing this
i would just stop so so yeah you explain
me more the reasoning behind yeah i
can't see
because from the outside watching maybe
mr beast now
putting like 10 child and have five
challenge
channels and like uploading so much
content on it
and like it for me maybe it's lose a bit
it's like a content machine that is a
business more than a youtube thing like
so yeah this is what i was watching from
outside i can't understand
yeah i do think there is such a thing as
too much but i don't think mr beast has
too much he
his thing is about reaching different
demographics and a different audience
and every channel like that like the
gaming channel is going to be different
than the main channel which is going to
be different from the shorts channel
uh and that's the same thing with us we
want to reach like the main channel is
education second channel's reaction
we've got a vlog is for people want to
see a vlog this is a podcast
so everything serves a different
audience in a different way
and we never really try to post more
than once a day so
every day if you want to watch a new
video you have it available
but but i do think there is a point
where it's like you can't just like on
the main channel
three is the limit if i posted every day
on the main channel people would get
overwhelmed and i think that would
actually
hurt but i think when you find the right
uh
the right ingredients to make a channel
you
have to keep that consistency and just
keep plowing through it
like if your channel does well like you
you should never miss an upload
ever that's probably one of the worst
things that you could do is oh
i don't feel like making a video i'm not
gonna because once you have an audience
and like that that's your obligation is
to the viewer
so same with us like we will never miss
an upload
on the iced coffee no matter what you
know like every sunday
sure i think there's once or twice we've
posted like an hour too late but we'll
never
miss an upload on something i'm allowed
to disagree right on the upload thing
now
you're not allowed to disagree
don't stop don't start crying i guess
all right
all right but yeah i think
if i think the goal is to upload the
best possible content for you is
different for me i think it's kind of
different because i cannot make
i'm only one person now have an editor
in my country i'm helping
i'm trying to find things out and learn
as fast as possible so i
feel comfortable with uploading not with
a schedule
whenever i can because i'm making these
videos that is impossible for me to make
it's very difficult so i don't think
upload schedule is for everyone but i
think for a lot of people
works i would disagree i would say there
are
very few channels you can get away with
uh no upload schedule i think uh the
only
the actually the only channel that i
would say that i've ever seen
be a success without a consistent upload
schedule is michael reeves
it's the only one we just told phidia he
didn't have him michael reason
his name yeah his views are down sure a
little bit
i believe his views are down only
because he's taken so much time off
and uh for for an algorithm too they
remind
robert mr beast dream all these guys
they don't have an upload schedule
ah but mark robert has what 20 million
subscribers
sometimes he meets the upload once a
month because he's already built up an
audience for years
i i think i'm a little bit more on video
society
for some creators it makes sense to have
an upload schedule such as us
but for some other creators like phidias
it just makes sense to put out the best
possible content you can do i mean look
at
who phidias is like gearing his content
towards like like mr beast
i remember i saw a tweet mr beast put
out like like a maybe a few weeks ago he
said
hey guys sorry i've thrown away the last
three videos if you're wondering why we
haven't posted in three weeks just
because i wasn't happy with the content
and i think that's what makes him
so successful as youtuber every video
puts out you know it's a good video and
grow like that i think we're confusing
people
who have already reached like the
pinnacle of success versus like what it
takes to get there
i think what it takes to get there is a
consistent upload schedule i think it's
a differentiate factor
as also so it's both so yeah some people
like for me to have a different video
that every every
and anything else on youtube it takes me
three four weeks to make this video so
for me this is um this is a way for me
to differentiate myself from the crowd
i think you need help um not like you
need help but like you need like an
assistant
i think i think you need someone to help
you and i think the best way the best
analogy to put this is like it's like
you need a chair with four legs and i
think one of those legs is like having a
good video the next one is being
authentic the next one
is a consistent upload schedule i don't
know what the what the other one was but
you but you need
you need four i don't know
i would say a good group of people it's
a title thumbnail let's say this is a
fourth one it's got to be marketable
so you you could technically have a
chair
with three legs that kind of stands up
without a consistent upload schedule but
it wouldn't be as sturdy
i think if you combine everything you
you have with a consistent upload
schedule where they know like every
monday at six they'll get a video no
matter what
i i think that sort of discipline in
getting in that schedule is going to
help
and everything as well yeah i agree as
well because when you see a person once
a month
is you are going to like him more if you
see him more once
per week so yeah i i kind of agree with
it but i believe it's a
balance so let's talk because a lot of
podcasts get to
to details that not a lot of people care
about
yeah so i let's talk about more broad
topics yeah i want to i want to ask you
what is the most difficult challenge
that you've done so far
it was when i went to the army in my
country
you went to the army in your country you
want to talk about that a little bit
not that much do you feel comfortable
talking
oh just when you were in the army yeah
it's just something you don't feel
comfortable talking about or you just
you just don't want to talk about no i i
can't talk about it so
and when i i went to
i don't think i said it ever publicly
but yeah
i i went to navy seal training in my
country
so i finished that was the most
difficult thing it took me eight months
of
training we started a lot of people and
we finished very few
that was the most difficult did you make
it
yeah you made it to be a navy seal that
explains the uh the feat
like like the the endurance wait wait
that explains
it you completed navy seal training
phrase so technically you could be a
navy seal
i i am an abc no
actually really yeah in my country it is
kind of different
and so i will explain this so i
i kind of feel like after but anyways so
uh
in my country we have to everyone have
to do army so it's mandatory so
i i you had the choice to go to
everywhere
and i chose the navy seal part in my
country they would say
frog my house it's oic in my country so
this is the
uh it's eight months of intense na
that they take the navy seal training in
united states and they make
their own so it's yeah i'm trained
navy seal wow and we have to do 14
months so it was eight months and then
another
six months how old were you at the time
i was 18
what made it so difficult
eight months of complete struggle like
what
what time do you like walking through an
average day what time do you wake up
i don't want to get into so many details
but
yeah but i'm not sure if i i'm gonna be
allowed to
get into the details of the training so
but yeah that's the
that's one of the most difficult thing
like people i think
they they don't know this about me so
uh that was one of the reasons that
i i believe i have such a discipline
because like it was very tense training
we we started like 70 people and we
finished only 13 people
and and like it was so mentally like
so i was like very struggling the
training so like
that's why i'm so happy now because
we're sitting a couch and it's our job
so
it's like so beautiful so i think yeah i
think that was a big
development thing for me just tell me
what time you wake up in the morning i'm
just curious
in the for the navy seal yeah every
it depends but every day five a.m it's
not okay
five a.m that's easy but when you sleep
at 2 a.m
it's kind of difficult
wow yeah so when people drop out you
said they
went from 70 to 13. do people just say
hey i can't do this anymore
they they get kicked out or how does
that work uh
they they say i'm out okay and they
ring the bell and they leave wow
yeah why didn't you ring the bell
i love talking about this stuff but i'm
kind of like comfortable
to answer that yeah the last question
why did that yeah
i don't think i like i like giving up
like it was more of an eco thing a pride
thing
i also saw this as an ultimate challenge
i was i was remembered like i will look
back in my life and what will
look if if i would see that i gave up
and like i left
so for me from the beginning that i went
it was very difficult for me especially
but i had no other choice it was only
one road
finishing so no other cool i asked him
right before you came down in here i
said
how do you maintain such a great
physique but only exercise every other
day
and i'm sure that had to contribute in
some way shape or form
the other day is still pretty good what
exercising every other day is
good yeah but he looks crazy man you
should see him with his shirt off
i want somebody to take this out of
[Music]
context
[Music]
tell us about your upcoming videos like
what what sort of challenges do you want
to push
put put yourself through next i am
i'm so excited like we have the best job
in the world and i just
want to have fun so i'm thinking the
best way for example i want to go to an
island with seven days with no food and
what
this is fun for me and i want to do this
now
i have a lot of ideas every day i'm
coming
one hour with ideas that i'm excited to
feel so
i have a lot of ideas would you do that
would i do that for seven days no food
and water no
no i mean that first of all that's just
not that's not what i enjoy
i would enjoy going to an island where
uh where i could work
with wi-fi seriously
what would make what would make me so
happy is if i could take this office
put it in like let's say hawaii for like
a week or two but i have this office
here but i just have a view of the ocean
like on the ocean i think would be
that's
yeah i think that sounds awesome i would
l i would snap by things i would do that
right now
so if i want to island for seven days
without food or water i'll do it
alone that's making oh alone
i don't know if i i would want to have
like a i'm just curious why what what
what makes that
appealing it's just like it's a once in
a lifetime opportunity
to do something like that and could do
that any time you could choose any but i
mean if you want to go into
unlikely that i actually will right but
what i'm saying is like
like think about it when you're on your
death bed okay at the end of your life
you're like
like did i accomplish everything that i
possibly wanted to and
could have accomplished and also who
knows if i'm gonna enjoy it or not i
haven't tried it
and what if i do actually end up hating
it but at least i have like i could say
like you know i did that for a week of
my life and i'm sure i'll learn
something too from the struggle and
like surviving i don't know it just
sounds like a crazy
awesome like once in a lifetime
experience well we could lock the fridge
from you for seven days and uh hunting
i would have to hunt so i watched this
video that
a person survived 300 days on an island
with only some minimum staff in life
i was really crying through this is what
i love like this is what
makes me thick what makes me excited and
i think that's why
it's it's it's kind of seems obvious to
me that i'm going to probably if i am
still alive with the video that i'm
doing
it i will probably be successful because
i'm willing to go the extra mile but i'm
enjoying it as well and that
that makes it so so easy for me to go in
an island for seven days
i'm looking forward i'm excited to do it
and i think that's why
i i will probably be
when are you gonna do that i don't know
maybe in in a month from now a month
have you identified the island
yeah it's going to be in mr beast island
oh it is going to be that one
yeah aren't there like pigs and stuff on
that island yeah but i will not eat
them i'm gonna like i mean
does he know about the island or he he
sold the island so it's not his so i
would be
transparent but i don't care to break
the rules should we should we
broadcast that on should we take it out
maybe maybe it's better we not
i don't care i'm sure it's funny okay
we're not condoning it
right right but i don't want someone to
foil your plan like they know the owner
or something like that and they're like
hey by the way videos that would make a
great video
get evicted from the island wow
yeah i think you know what i thought
would make would have made a great vlog
we missed it
told alex to do this last week was the
hottest day
ever on record in death valley 134
degrees
i told alex to go and visit death valley
on that day and you told alex to go yes
you didn't want to go i was i was in l.a
ever recorded on the planet and it's
death valley 45 minutes away how do you
not take that opportunity to be the
the host stay on earth yeah i would
drive there
i would drive there and just be like yep
it's hot
time to go oh i don't know get your hand
out the window
all right there we go
yeah yeah but i mean that would have
been an interesting video surviving 24
hours
on the hottest day on earth let's do it
for
five days without water and then i'm
excited
what makes you excited about like not
having water or food in like
five days i like challenging myself and
i don't think i challenge myself if i
go to a place that i it will not be
challenging for me okay
because i have like uh mental
capabilities and discipline i did a lot
of stuff in the
past so i feel like i want to push
myself every time more and i think
that's why the videos will get crazier
and bigger in my opinion
got it okay so it's kind of like david
blaine yeah yeah yeah yeah i could see
that
i i i i cried every time i watched his
video his
big inspiration like i love you this is
crazy
madness i think you love him as well
right
yeah he's awesome
yeah similar to this seven days buried
alive i
survived 30 days on toe in in the clouds
that was crazy that was crazy
and his stuff is really real he is
speaking about
yeah his stuff is real which is nuts i
listen i loved his podcast with joe
rogan about how he does a lot of these
tricks
they're all just training years of
training to be able to like regurgitate
a frog
and like fill your stomach with like
enough fluid to like the frogs don't die
in there it's
nuts i noticed that maybe he's some
his brain sells maybe he said he can
turn off pain
he said he can just turn it off and
that's how he puts the needle in his arm
that was how it's rumored that um
who who is the uh the the buddhist
uh i forgot gandhi no it wasn't gandhi
that
i hate the the one who burned themselves
alive and it's that famous picture
it's a famous picture of the monk
the [ __ ] it was damn
it was the rage against the machine like
uh album cover
but anyway uh apparently this monk was
able to get in such a meditative state
that they would not feel pain is it uh
tit maybe can you turn around show me
the picture it's funny i can see this
picture
yeah wait can i see yeah
yeah that's anyway yeah that's so
interesting right
what the human can do in the human
potential and like how you he can't do
all this stuff
it's so interesting yeah and i believe i
mean it makes sense that uh if you train
your mind
long enough that you should be able to
cut off because pain is just a threshold
this thing like hey don't do this
it's bad it's going to hurt you yes just
neurons right
so if you like find a way to exactly
right the message is that the neural
sense that this is painful maybe okay
i don't know yeah same with david blaine
and like the it's it with the gag reflex
let's say for him
swallowing certain things it's just it's
training it's it's overcoming that your
body's ability to be like oh no this
gotta come out
what else what do you think graham or me
or alex or anyone here could improve on
like what could we be doing better in in
your vision i think
he's a great adapt in the vlog he's a
great character i think
like me in the air videos i think
people like me because of my innocence
and like of my
actually love being there and like he
have the same thing and maybe better
than me like it feels like i know he's
halting the camera i think
he's doing a great job i think he can
spend more time on youtube analytics to
understand
the retention graphs and stuff and that
will improve a lot the editing process
i think you are doing a a great job
i think you can push yourself to to
read more books and like push yourself
to
do different things and improve faster
and i think what about you
i think you have to make shorter outros
i actually agree with that that's fair
yeah that's fair
i'll take it and also i think you can
make more evergreen videos because i
think
how i think about youtube is more about
the long term like if you see mr beast
views he's getting
views from the videos that he uploaded
two years ago and that's like a big
thing so
if you make a video about a currency
that is
like bitcoin and whatever it was
ditch coin that you made the last video
i think i think
yeah how i think about evergreen videos
i got
this again from a philosopher nassim
taleb he said about
uh to make something relevant
for a lot of years you have to think
about it it will how
much history you have so for example
cars have like 50 years of history it's
more likely to be around
for the next 50 years so when you make a
video about dick
coin whatever that is it's not
mo likely to be relevant in two years
from now so i think
making videos that are relevant three
years from now it's
will improve a lot the long-term growth
i think yeah the problem with that is uh
there's only so many evergreen videos
that i could make
so i could make like one a day but
within three weeks it'd be out for the
year
we tried with a video where i invested a
hundred thousand dollars in a stock
picking monkey
because i feel like that regardless of
well i guess there is the time that the
there's the time yeah stuff like that
right i think guys
maybe i i think don't think you are
maybe if you think more outside the box
it will be like i don't say that i know
everything about this but
maybe invest now some money on this and
like
see one year from now the results in
like
whatever think more long term there is
so much stuff if you are
creative and think outside the box i
don't think there is excuses that is ah
so much evergreen videos this is just my
opinion maybe i'm stupid it's fair
that's fair well jack we'll think about
uh more evergreen videos we can do that
how what do you think guys i can improve
as well
so this is within the realm of like
youtube and posting and stuff like that
everything like me by behaving making
crumbs cry
or whatever what how
do you think i can improve what do you
think graham consistency
if that's the only thing that i think
you could do that would uh
that would take you to the next level
big schedule stick with it no matter
what
i think that same dedic you could do it
though because that that's what irks me
is that
you have the discipline to do it you'll
find a way
if you tell yourself every tuesday 6 p.m
i'm going to post
a a video i am so proud of no matter
what
you could do it man if you could run a
half marathon
and mess up your feet like that if you
could spend a week at an airport if you
could
go on an island and not eat for a week
you will find a way to make it happen
i know you will a hundred percent and
then my only other thing is
see if you could find someone who's just
like you who could work with you on this
just like iraq has uh what was
mac mac you mean as a character in the
videos helping me in the business
whatever you whatever you want i i don't
think they need to be a character in the
video i think
i think probably your personality is
enough to fill the entire channel
maybe they're a bit of a side character
they don't need to be in it they could
just be
behind the scenes just helping you uh
bounce ideas back and forth
filming editing and then you're just
responsible for being in front of the
camera
to do this alone is is pretty difficult
to grow at the scale that you want to
grow at and everything
i i think i agree with that i think it
would help yeah you know it reminds me
of uh
how brave wilderness grew have you seen
that channel
coyote peterson yeah and for for a year
and a half
he was one of the most i don't want to
say one of the most viewed channels but
uh
all of his videos were like number one
trending every single one but he had
this series where he would get stung by
insects
and then just review it basically um
he's not doing that on his own i mean
he's traveling with two or three people
at all times who are
filming and he's just responsible for
being in front of the camera
that could be you is that you're so good
on camera
i don't know if i if i would uh bother
with like
filming and stuff like some of it
firsthand filming you could do but
i think if you found someone who could
be on board with you who gets in early
too like as you're growing to be a part
of it
um and just you know if you want to
split a portion of the channel with them
so that they're
equally invested or work out a flat fee
just
find some way to pay them i think that
would do well
but bring someone on you need to partner
in this one so i will get someone who's
who's good at all the things that uh
that you don't need to spend time on you
you from your experience you think
giving a portion
on your channel to your editor to the
people uh that you work with you think
this is a good move
would probably be cheaper to to give a
flat thing
but my so it's two things one it would
be cheaper
if you're like hey i'll give you x
amount per video
but they might not feel as enticed it
might not feel like motivated to to
watch you grow as well i mean jack you
what do you think i mean dude
i mean obviously jack's answer is gonna
no i i would i would i would probably
agree
that it's better to give a person
yeah i do but it depends because like if
they're just
an editor then no but if they if they
provide
more than being an editor like they're
they're they're they want to
they want to see you grow as a brand
maybe not just like the the success of
the channel but they want to
push you up in any way that they can
like they aid in that way as well then i
would make
i think it does make sense that's that's
a good point yeah if you just need
editing just hire an editor if you just
need a filmer
just hire a film because you'll be able
to direct the people as you want it so
you'll be able to get the
same product um but yeah that's that's a
good point
i can't see the value that you're saying
because
you i i don't care about like short-term
money i care about the long-term thing
and like if you
have people invested in your child you
are naturally going to perform long
long term better yeah because they are
going to be more motivated learning more
and be more excited
yeah i think that i see this with with
mark and eric like
he might have a portion in the whole
thing and like he when eric is not there
like
maggie mark shout out to mike he's so
talented
so credit or great motivated like
with the right people like when arag is
not there
mark is like he's not joking like
because they have a skin in the game in
there i think
like he let's do this let's do he's
pushing yeah
and like you want this i think you need
a macro jack
if they're not a mac or a jack or an
alex
then um then i would just say uh
just find someone first so you are
saying that it have to be as well very
specific to
with with who yeah it's very difficult
yeah and maybe it's too early right now
maybe you need to continue growing and
seeing like if there's a budget or
what's involved so you know a little bit
more like
i i would say this get post a consistent
schedule make a consistent schedule once
a week
post always there do that for like four
months
maybe three months and you'll know
within three months if you if you can
afford someone else
what you could pay them and what you
need i'd say once a week is a too
too severe of a change like once every
like two weeks is i feel like a little
bit more reasonable
gram i love you but i will not follow
your advice on the posting thing because
i
i
i will tell you my thing and like five
years from now
i want the videos to be good and like i
cannot make that
once a week because the idea have to be
ever green the video have to be
optimized for new viewers
all these is going a lot too and for
example i'm making
i have a hundred thousand subscribers
and we are getting 300 000 views
so there is some interesting behind this
how you get more views on your channel
so i think
making this optimized video for five
years uh
be real still relevant it takes a lot so
i think
i will upload when as soon as i can
upload i will work every day 24 7 as
soon as i can upload i will upload yeah
so for to have goal as a subscriber
number like for me to have a subscriber
goal
it's better for me to have like how many
members will convert into
being in payment this will mean like i
will have to connect better with the
viewers i have to
show more of myself i have to give more
of myself what do you think
yeah i think you could still have
dedicated people who don't need to pay
five dollars a month
and you will get the people who who can
financially support the channel like
that
but i think some of our most dedicated
people are not the the members i don't
i don't know if we have memberships
turned on on the iced coffee hour i
don't think so
um but i would say even on the main
channel
the most dedicated subscribers are not
members but they're just like they're
the first to come
we got the first like grand fan what's
up grandfather
dgb josh yeah jeff roonsville
wow yeah did you be anthony
yeah baton is every video he knows we
chat with him
every day literally almost every day we
talk to matan
for and we've done that for months yeah
i had my
uh by the way what i said before maybe
i'm stupid just think
different ways to do stuff and i'm just
want to stress them with clever people
to ask is this a good idea or not
but another thing that you i think you
do i told to
jack about it like being able to say in
one video of yours that guys we
responded to 70
of your comments that sticks stick to me
for years yeah
so this is a way to connect with them so
i think that
that was kind of very yeah i'd spent
probably two hours a day if i were you
responding to all the comments as often
as you can it does help
we do that on the ice con this episode's
gonna pose jack you're you're probably
commenting right now yeah i get to like
all the comments
first day yeah yeah it really it's it's
good and it shows
it shows that you're appreciative so
that's what i would do
i mean it's going to be hard at some
point but an hour a day
hour a day just wake up an hour earlier
respond to comments in bed before you
wake up
i love you guys i love you guys thank
you for bringing me here it was
really beautiful being here thank you so
much everyone else is beautiful
free stock down below in the description
it's worth all the way up to 70 dollars
no oh i thought i thought you were going
to say bankrollcoffee.com
yeah but that okay that's that's the
next most beautiful thing is
bankrollcoffee.com our coffee is now
officially for sale we just got uh
i think we got like 30 000 bags
30
[Music]
yeah so basically all that we didn't
make any profit but basically all the
sales that came in now just got
reinvested there was like a
like i don't know five percent profit
now we got more bags
you know what's better guys you not
getting this
once at a time be buying regular this
make it your regular coffee oh yeah yeah
that's right we started a subscription
so i i think it's if you if you join the
subscription you save 10
like an extra 10 or something i think i
think it's on the website but anyway the
subscription is where it's at but try it
first
you're going to like it but just peace
of mind you're going to like it and then
enjoy so thanks so much for watching
guys
and until next time